we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors magic spoon is the cereal that
tastes exactly like the delicious
cereals from your childhood except it
has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect for a keto
diet to get free shipping go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman blinkist
is the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman
yesterday joe biden officially secured
270 electoral votes as all 50 states had
their electors
formally cast their ballots so
yes this is the end except it already
was the end
before and anyway the trump cultists are
still coming up with new ideas
and again moving the goal posts which we
will get to but for those of you
who like me prefer to live in reality
you may recall that on november 3rd
the people voted in their states in a
state election which would determine
which electors would vote on december
14th which was yesterday
in the states where joe biden got more
votes on november 3rd
democratic electors cast electoral votes
for joe biden
in states where donald trump got more
votes on november 3rd
republican electors cast electoral votes
for donald trump
joe biden was expected to receive 306
electoral votes
based on the results from november 3rd
and indeed he did without a single
faithless elector based on the order in
which states voted california
shortly after 5 pm eastern cast its 55
electoral votes
for joe biden that officially put joe
biden over 270. so let's look at that
for a moment
from the california state house
yesterday i will now nice to
announce the tally of the vote for the
office of president of the united states
for joseph r biden of delaware a
democrat
eyes 55 knows zero
and with that joe biden now officially
the president-elect now remember
on no saturday november 7th i believe it
was
numerous media outlets started um
calling joe biden the president-elect
they called the election for joe biden
that night joe biden addressing the
nation and people like donald trump and
others said the media does not get to
call
the election in any official sense and
the media doesn't decide who is
president-elect
now that was true then it was also true
in 2016 but in 2016 donald trump was
glad to accept the media's call
but now it is not the media it is the
electors
that have voted so is this it well
trump is say no because they still have
january 6th
january 6 what happens then on january 6
the house and senate hold a joint
session to count the electoral votes
and mike pence will oversee that as vice
president
um al gore oversaw that in the year 2000
when he was defeated by george w
bush and mike pence will oversee it on
january 6th as he has been defeated as
well
so the new goal post this is the point
the new goal post is that on january 6
republicans in the house and senate
during that joint session of congress to
count electoral votes
are going to have objections ready to go
it's likely that
when georgia uh when george's turn comes
to say we give our votes to joe biden or
pennsylvania
you will see a republican members of the
house and or senate stand and object
and mike pence will say for what reason
does the gentle lady from texas rise
today or whatever
and they will have some objection and
the goal
of that per the trumpist is
to prevent this from actually happening
on january 6th now it's going to happen
that this is what what's going to happen
on january 6th
you can already imagine the triggering
and donald trump absolutely losing his
mind yesterday as joe biden won the
electoral college
later in the evening joe biden
addressing the nation and trump just
tweeting and retweeting nonsense for
hours
posting debunked baseless election
conspiracy theory after theory
with apparently no understanding or
sense whatsoever that he's embarrassing
not only himself but the country
some example tweets i can't post them
all i like you too much to post all of
the to show
you all of them but some example tweets
from trump include
dominion voting machines are a disaster
all over the country
change the results of a landslide
election can't let this happen
thank you for the genius bravery and
patriotism of the judge
should get a medal no evidence
whatsoever of any of that
trump also tweeting many trump votes
were routed
to biden the highly respected michigan
judge released this epic
report true all over the country this
fake election can no longer stand
get moving republicans big swing state
win
75 million votes that is also a
completely baseless claim
which was flagged by twitter as such so
the good news is
we're getting closer guys it's it's not
that much longer
and trump will be gone and a major step
yesterday with joe biden becoming a
president-elect with 306 electoral votes
cast in their respective state houses
for president-elect joe biden and in the
midst of all of this
as if it wasn't an insane enough day
already attorney general william barr
has resigned let's discuss that next
so another big story yesterday the
resignation
of donald trump's delusional depraved
dystopian uh what other d words there's
many
attorney general william barr he has
resigned maybe he got fired as with all
of these things
we never really know when a resignation
is claimed whether it was really a
resignation or whether it was a firing
but donald trump yesterday saying that
indeed
william barr is departing on december
23rd
sort of generally speaking the reason
given is that barr wants to go spend
time with his family
okay as you may recall um william barr
was it last week or the week before time
is so weird right now
in the last couple weeks william barr
came out and said despite what donald
trump wanted
bar to say barr said as of right now
there is no evidence of election fraud
that would have any impact on the
election results
and donald trump didn't like this and
many republicans and trump
didn't like it but it was the truth um
and there were rumors that william barr
may be fired and there were
claims that donald trump was thinking
about firing william barr
this is being called a resignation at
this point in time
donald trump tweeting as if it was all
super friendly
and super nice sort of a nothing to see
here tweeting quote just had a very nice
meeting with attorney general william
barr at the white house
our relationship has been a good one
he's done an outstanding job
as per letter bill will be leaving just
before christmas
to spend the holidays with his family
deputy attorney general jeff rosen an
outstanding person will become acting
attorney general
highly respected richard donahue will be
taking over the duties of deputy
attorney general
thank you to all now hilariously
barr's letter to trump is barely about a
resignation
it's a two-page letter the entire first
page
is weaponized brown nosing as i'm
calling it barr
thanks trump for letting him investigate
voter fraud
uh bar thanks uh congratulates trump on
operation warp
speed i mean just a completely
sycophantic letter it's just a riot
but then the second page is is like one
line
and on the second page bar just says as
discussed i will spend the next week
wrapping up and will depart on december
23rd
just a sort of casual i'm out of here so
the speculation
is that barr quit or was fired because
he refused to do the things trump
wanted him to do i think it's really
important to understand that while that
may well be true
um this actually reminds me of the brian
kemp
situation in georgia brian kemp is the
republican governor of georgia brad
raffensberger is the republican
secretary of state of georgia
and when donald trump was insisting in
pressuring and pressuring
kemp and raffensberger to somehow steal
the election from joe biden in georgia
brian kemp and brad raffensberger
refused and there were people saying
look these are the
these are the good republicans they're
unwilling to do this stuff
remember that brian kemp is disgusting
brian kemp as secretary of state
ran for governor and participated in one
of the greatest acts of
election suppression voter suppression
in georgia
when he faced off against stacey abrams
it's not that brian kemp is a good guy
it's that for just about anybody there
is a low below which they will not go
there is the there is some place where
they say this i can't do
and brian kemp in all likelihood
recognized
that even if he was able to find some
completely authoritarian way
to try to steal georgia from joe biden
and give it to trump
trump still doesn't become president of
the united states and so brian kemp made
the political calculation that he wasn't
going to get involved
similarly william barr okay maybe barr
left because he wasn't willing to do
things trump wanted him to do or maybe
trump
fired barr because barr wasn't willing
to do it look at the things barr was
willing to do including that ridiculous
four-page propaganda letter
making completely incorrect claims in
advance of the mueller report like trump
was completely exonerated
when the mueller report said we cannot
exonerate donald trump completely from
obstruction so barr
is no good guy but it's certainly
plausible
that barr had to draw a line somewhere
it's also possible that barr wants to
get out before trump starts some really
humiliating stuff over the next month
which is
expected to include some absurd
short-term appointments
deranged cronyistic pardons that trump
is expected to give
even borderline seditious last-ditch
efforts to steal the election so
bar is no good guy he's horrible he's
bailing out or was encouraged to resign
or was fired
and that is as far as we can say it
beyond that
bar is no one to be applauded think
about how much has happened in the last
three days we're so desensitized
to the speed of the news the last three
days have seen
coronavirus vaccination start for a
hundred year pandemic
the supreme court throwing out a legal
challenge on which trump and
others had hung their entire expectation
for stealing the election
joe biden officially winning the
electoral vote after five months of
trump's lies and coup attempts
and the attorney general william barr
either resigning or getting fired
all in the last three days on january
1st
we will have a huge one day
membership special to kick off 2021
strongly and i look forward uh to having
you
participate simply get on our mailing
list
at joinpakman.com to be notified on
january 1st
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of
protein so it's perfect for someone on a
low carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100 percent of your money if you
don't love it
no questions asked go to magicspoon.com
pacman to build your own custom variety
box today
make sure to use promo code pacman to
get free shipping
the link is right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that we are mostly funded by
memberships
from nice people like you who sign up at
joinpacman.com
use the coupon code fresh start
if you want a huge discount and you'll
get the daily
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show the daily members only bonus
show
and lots of other really great stuff
joinedpakman.com is the place
all right let's have some fun uh we're
going to do a
whirlwind tour through the last 24 hours
on fox news
as joe biden officially won the
electoral college donald trump lost it
we already talked about this
officially yesterday december 14th state
electors
voting and joe biden got 306 electoral
votes it is over
it was over before it's extra over now
so
all sorts of people appeared on fox news
and they were dealing with this loss in
a variety of different ways
joe biden said during his speech last
night when he addressed the nation
that donald trump attempted an assault
on democracy in trying to steal the
election and that's accurate and that
leads to our first clip
here is donald trump's press secretary
and senior campaign advisor
which one she was last night i don't
know reacting to joe biden's accurate
claim
about donald trump trying to assault
democracy and she's
really upset guys and this just before
coming to air
we heard joe biden say that there was an
assault on democracy
by president trump asking for a free and
fair election
that's preposterous how fitting is your
monologue tonight the assault on
democracy
was the four-year attack going after
president trump the baseless molar
allegations
uh the the impeachment over a one
whistleblower with hearsay
so she's very upset there or at least
pretending to be
and this is just so simple but they want
to make it more complex
joe biden won this election because he
won enough states
to get more than 270 electoral votes
that's it
and then donald trump despite losing
tried to remain in power so
it is an assault on the democratic will
of the people period end of story very
simple
they either don't get it or they pretend
not to get it here's laura ingraham in
our next clip
sort of begrudgingly conceding that it
is
president-elect joe biden but she had to
do it
in a sarcastic tone okay take a look
following the electoral college vote
today
president-elect joe biden spoke to the
nation tonight
listen as long as you acknowledge that
he's president-elect
i don't care if you use a minnie mouse
voice i don't care if you say
president-elect joe biden as chewbacca
i don't care as long as you're
understanding that joe biden is the
president-elect
this next one is just delightful even
trump supporter and friend of trump
geraldo rivera has to admit it's over
and wild trump sycophant charlie kirk
just can't take it
and starts arguing with geraldo live on
air let's first listen to what geraldo
had to say
the modern history of our country but to
persist
in insisting against the supreme court
against the
scores of lawsuits that have gone
against him every single one of them
that he won that's why these people they
believe him
they love him they are following his
lead
it is the president who is instilling in
these people
the false sense that they have been
gypped charlie makes the point that
uh there are there's so many uh
affidavits or hero there you litigate
each one of them if someone's guilty of
election fraud you put them in jail
the attorney general of the united
states william bohr said that there is
no
fraud that he has seen of a scope large
enough to affect the outcome of this
election
charlie charlie go ahead so i'm not
thrilled with geraldo's use of the word
gypt it's sort of like saying you've
been jude i'm not
canceling geraldo it's not the main
point of the clip but
i've stopped using that term but the
sentiment here is correct
and charlie kirk doesn't like it and if
you try to say something sensible on fox
news you get attacked and that's what
happened here
and here's charlie kirk very upset with
geraldo elections were very much on the
margins especially in georgia and
arizona
and you suppress that conversation that
is not healthy for our country geraldo
all right so that raises the question
for six weeks we have litigated this for
six weeks twice the supreme court of the
united states
have rejected it nine to nothing
including all three
trump associate justices
so that's pretty funny they they just
can't take it
and then as a sort of contrast here's
the news side of fox news
which is often not very newsy but even
they did say yesterday brett baer saying
joe biden has officially won well what
is normally a rubber stamp process
was anything but today and moments ago
the electoral college voted
for president in what may be its most
watched event in decades
making joe biden the 46th president
of the united states right now
president-elect correspondent brian yen
such an uncontroversial statement that
one from brett bayer
which got magga twitter absolutely
furious with bret bayer and these are
some
wild times that we live in and a little
bit later i'm actually going to talk
about a very interesting
sort of milestone for fox news a
negative milestone
regarding ratings and the bigger picture
is i am very curious to see what fox
news will look like
um january 21st and beyond not that much
longer now we'll know very soon
this is a beautiful video this is a
perfect video that i'm going to play for
you
this is what you call a political
trapeze artist
flying around wildly trying to keep it
all together
i've told you before that republicans
have been causing a problem
for themselves in georgia because on the
one hand they're insisting and trump has
been insisting
that the november presidential election
was rigged against him
he won but it was rigged and so joe
biden
claims to have won the votes can't be
trusted the georgia republican governor
can't be trusted
the georgia republican secretary of
state is in on it they're bad people
it's all rigged
and at the same time trump and the two
republican senate candidates in georgia
kelly lefler
and david perdue these are the races
that will determine who controls the
senate after their january 5th runoffs
they've been saying
yeah it was rigged against trump and
make sure to vote for us on january 5th
what because the obvious question is
we we there's a contradiction there the
election was
rigged against trump and presumably also
rigged against them in november
maybe loffler and perdue would have won
had it not been rigged
but because of the rigging now they have
runoffs but wouldn't the runoffs also be
rigged by their own logic
this all came to a glorious crescendo
yesterday on fox and friends when
lefleur was interviewed and she was
asked
why wouldn't the january runoffs be just
as rigged as the november election and
she just can't she literally cannot
explain it take a look at this
we've heard from the president who said
that the election was stolen from him
that it was rigged in november so for
the people of georgia who are thinking
about
early voting what can you say to them
they've heard
the election was rigged in november so
why vote now
well steve great question because we've
built a
robust organization to make sure that
every legal vote is counted and every
illegal vote is thrown out
so what's different now than it was in
november where it's no longer
rigged yeah so we're in the courts right
now
asking for better signature verification
processes a bipartisan verification
to have consistent verification county
to county
as well as the addition of four thousand
poll watchers we also have a statewide
organization getting out the vote
one thousand workers going across the
state backed by forty thousand
volunteers
if we vote we will win if we don't vote
we will lose the country
we are the firewall to socialism and you
saw in my debate
last week i'm running against the most
radically liberal candidate that has
ever run for the senate
he's someone that would defund the
police he refused to renounce
socialism we have to push back against
this radical agenda of the left and it's
up to georgia voters to do
that great question she says and and
listen to her her explanations
we now have an organization to count
every legal vote
well right but that's that's you're
doing that for november
how does that even relate to what has
changed in the system
she says we're in the courts well but
none of that's going anywhere
and then she says we're really working
hard to get out the vote get out the
vote is campaigning it has nothing to do
with rigging
and then she just goes into socialism
and attacks her opponent rafael warnock
she can't answer the question so she
just has her buzz words from the debate
but this was a totally different
question if you believe it was rigged in
november
and your vote wasn't counted accurately
or at all
why would you vote this time because
nothing has changed
and it's a great question and she says
well because my opponents are radical
okay that's not really an answer and
it's actually a disaster and really
depressing that these races in georgia
are even close
but they are close in uh john ossoff
versus david perdue the average of
recent polling is ossof plus one
which means it's tied could go either
way which means you have to vote
in lefleur versus warnock it's warnock
plus 1.6
again whether you do or don't trust
these polls you have to vote if we trust
these polls it's close and we have to
vote
if we don't trust these polls we don't
know how close it is
so we have to vote either way we have to
vote
and it would be a major accomplishment
major accomplishment
to be able to after everything that's
gone down take control of the senate
50-50 with kamala as the deciding vote
january 5th is the day uh just a few
weeks left
and we will know who is ultimately going
to control the senate
a twitter spokesperson has confirmed to
fox i'm sorry to forbes
that after inauguration day donald trump
can be banned from twitter right now
twitter has a rule
called the world leaders policy which
means that the social media company
typically will leave up any tweets from
world leaders even if they violate
twitter policy at a more uh granular
level
and their explanation is when it's a
head of state
people want to see what heads of state
are saying and so even if the comments
violate
twitter policy we leave them up and
that's the policy
that has allowed donald trump to spread
conspiracy theories about
coronavirus and uh the election and
tweet threats and
get people bullying others without being
punished
and the protection will stop when trump
is no longer president on january 20th
now
the reality is he's never really been a
leader but he has
technically been the president of the
united states the normal process when
you don't have world leader protection
is that the first time you tweet
something that violates policy your
account is blocked
until you delete that tweet the second
time you break policy
your account is frozen for some period
of time that happened to don jr
i think it was 12 hours over false
claims about coronavirus
might have been about hydroxychloroquine
and eventually you would be banned
altogether
if donald trump does get banned by
twitter it will trigger him incredibly
and it would be a pleasure to watch
but i would rather twitter get rid of
the rule that you can be exempt from the
guidelines
everybody should have to play by the
same rules and if that were the case
donald trump would already have been
banned for targeting people
for bullying people for consistently
spreading disinformation about elections
and public health matters
shouldn't you be held to a higher
standard as president because in
practice what twitter is saying
is we hold world leaders to a lower
standard
and that seems counterintuitive to me
now there's an interesting kind of
side story here which is that donald
trump has been losing twitter followers
since he lost the election if you look
at socialblade which tracks data
for social accounts of all kinds it
shows that over the last 30 days trump
has lost about 300 000 followers that's
about
10 000 followers per day and this is
interesting because we've been covering
the many ways in which the world has
been moving on from donald trump
and donald trump throughout his
presidency gained followers
and now he is losing followers and again
the world is moving on now big picture
i actually like world leaders being on
twitter
uh i follow justin trudeau i follow
you know argentinian elected officials
and i followed the french president and
i like hearing from elected officials in
this direct way
what trump does really wrong is he
tweets things that affect
policy or he tweets new policy without
even communicating with anybody that
he's planning to do that the military
trans ban
is one where jim mattis the secretary of
the defense was traveling and unaware
trump was doing this and trump tweeted
it and it creates chaos
and of course the brazen way in which
trump uses the bully pulpit
uh to target bullying at individuals and
to spread disinformation it's disgusting
but
trump aside i like world leaders being
on twitter
let me know what you think we'll have
more coverage of this on our instagram
page which you can find
at david pakman show the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
welcome back to the david pakman show
today we're going to be speaking with
graham wood who's a
journalist writes for the atlantic also
author of the book the way
of the strangers um really glad to have
you on graham looking forward to this
thanks for having me david so let's talk
a little bit about the concept of a
failed state
um there are those who have been
attributing the term failed state to the
united states
in the context of the failure to mount
a reasonable response to the coronavirus
pandemic
very high rate of per capita cases
and death others have been talking about
the u.s as a failed state in the context
of trump's failed leadership in the u.s
increasingly being pushed aside on
conversations of climate and and so many
others
the idea of a failed state and that we
had a sitting president
tried to subvert the will of the people
so brazenly as donald trump tried to
keep the the the white house
even despite losing to joe biden
uh what's your sense of how accurate
this term is and how we should think
about that
well first of all i think the term
failed state as you as you point out
it it's got a diversity of effects it's
it's sometimes just a state that doesn't
exist it's sometimes a state that is
malevolent
sometimes a state that that um doesn't
do its job well and i think
of the of the three we've probably seen
most of
of of the last one but with with touches
of the other ones
so when i think of other states that
have failed
um they're all of course horrible
humanitarian disasters
somalia probably being the most famous
example from the last few decades
and i don't see as moving in to that
position
what i do see is enough institutions of
government that have broken down
that uh you could be forgiven for
thinking that
that the pressure tests just
exposed huge huge flaws
and shortcomings in government and
the the most worrying thing first of all
is that they exist and second of all
there seems to be no remedy
for them they don't seem to be getting
any better
and there's there's no impetus certainly
with the current administration
to do what i would say that the
necessary work
would be to correct them yeah a lot of
it is
failed uh failure to meet expectations
right the
uh when we talk about a failed state
it's not necessarily
some of the things you mentioned but
it's we might have imagined than those
who believe in american exceptionalism
might have imagined
we would have been one of the best
countries in dealing with the pandemic a
rich country with so many resources so
so
maybe a lot of it is about the failure
to meet expectations
same applies to the democratic uh thing
as we might call it uh with regard to
the 2020 election just not what people
expected
yeah so i i think we can go beyond
politics too
i mean the tools that the world has used
to handle the pandemic successfully
where it's done so successfully
uh we're largely american creations i
mean american
ingenuity created things like pcr
for example that has been deployed at
scale with great success
in smaller countries with fewer
resources than
we in the united states have so you
start seeing the
the expectations just not not being
lived up to
that's that's i think the main thing i
mean there's also though the fact that
the united states
has really never stopped thinking of
itself as uh
in in idealistic terms whereas other
countries i think have
have um been more cynical about their
role in the world
so you know it's not as likely i think
to find
say someone who's uh from the uk
thinking
that the uk is going to be a beacon for
hope
that the the model of the uk is going to
be exported elsewhere
as americans we we inherit that that's
that's part of our legacy
and so we also see ourselves failing
to live up to not just our capacities
but our ideals that we
tell ourselves and then to a large
extent tell other people too
you know i got uh very interesting phone
calls in the last couple of weeks
from since the election from british and
belgian viewers
a british and a belgian viewer and they
said you know
david in watching the election take
place in the run-up to november 3rd
and what happened there and after um
it's really weird to see people talking
about
our democracy in a campaign like a
discussion of
the concept of our democracy in a
campaign our democracy being at risk
or an attack on democracy that uh it was
unusual to even see
that discussion and it would be unusual
in places like the uk and belgium and
and maybe others
what's your thought about that yeah i
think to a lot of the world americans
look very naive
i mean we think that these stories we
tell ourselves
are true uh we don't assume that they're
offered in a
purely cynical way and i think that's a
good thing about the united states
and it's something that i actually wish
other countries
would um would do a bit more of maybe
with
with with the uh with some revisions
as i wish that we would do it with some
revisions you know there's there's so
much discussion of the sins of america
and the sins actually happened so yeah
we revise our idealism
on that basis but when a belgian hears
us talk about
what the importance is of american
democracy
if you're a belgian that there is no
current strain of belgian thought that
suggests that maybe the belgian model is
the savior of mankind
uh there's definitely a living version
of american exceptionalism that believes
exactly that
so um somewhere in the middle is
probably the right right place but
it means that the failure of the united
states politically
in public health is all that more
all that much more heartbreaking i think
to americans what is your
sense of where and how unrest
and maybe violence would would develop
um
there is speculation you know both sides
love to say the other side is really the
violent one
i believe that when you look at
political violence uh the
the groups that study this have found
that it really is
disproportionately from the right
against the left
but you know there's been speculation
about um
yesterday's milestone the certification
the voting of the electors could trigger
violence
or january 6th
or january 20th these different dates um
what do you what is your sense about
what we might expect and what might
really lead to
such violence yeah i mean my tendency
i'm sort of an empiricist i'm a reporter
i go places
and see things and work from there
rather than generalizing trends and then
making predictions
from there so i i i'm guessing that
going forward we're more likely to see
things that are totally unforeseen come
up rather than than
um things like republicans stab in the
back kind of narratives
for example being the ones that that
that that define
the the unrest in the year to come so
what i'm most worried about
is uh various unforeseen things that
could blossom into much much more so you
take for example something like
george floyd there's plenty of examples
of police brutality of racism
that particular one i don't think any of
us could have predicted that
it would spark what it did and
incidents like that will happen more and
more it's it's never been easier to take
one incident that may very well be
illustrative or emblematic or
a good example of a larger trend and
then turn them into something that
you could never predicted what they
would would become so
whenever there is any kind of armed
um protest whenever there is a face-off
between
militias say in an american city which
seems to happen
as a matter of course whenever there's
any kind of public demonstration
you have the possibility where there
will be a gun battle in america in an
american city
that could mean dozens of people killed
i hope that doesn't happen
but where does that start it starts with
one gunshot and
i'm worried that there might be
something that that that begins
in that totally unpredictable and even
almost random way uh and the effects of
that
could be could be rippling and enormous
yeah what you're really talking about is
the importance
of what nasim nicholas talib calls
black swans right these rare events
which by their nature are unpredictable
risk models don't account for them risk
models that say we are accounting for
really rare events
don't um talib kind of elaborates on
this further in his book fooled by
randomness it even takes
a important important role in his book
anti-fragile these are these are the
fundamentally
difficult to to predict events and
that's what makes it so difficult to
answer these questions
yeah that's right these are are
spontaneous events uh
and they are extremely contingent on you
know
if it's a single gunshot that erupts
that that that
gun battle that i i hypothesized before
then
it could be because that person leaned
on his gun the wrong way it could be
that he
he you know didn't have a good breakfast
that morning
that kind of thing is usually what what
causes to causes
um events to be to be um kicked into
motion
i mean if we were to look back a year
ago there are some things we could have
predicted
some things we couldn't have we could
have predicted that the president of the
united states
would display all the traits that he's
shown in the rest of his political life
those things yes but the very fact that
we we saw
this failed pressure test of of the
regulatory and other apparatus of the
united states to the pandemic
probably not something that anybody um
you know had on the bingo card so
that kind of thing i think is much more
likely to define 2021
than uh anything that that could be
easily foreseen
i have this idea that i'm curious to get
your thoughts on about
there are competing forces that sort of
make it less likely that you will see
mass rallies huge protests in the united
states to the level that they sort of
start shutting down
aspects of the economy or cities or
whatever the case may be and it's
on the one hand you have the combination
of ready access to credit
and cheap stuff from china and other
countries
which keeps a lot of people just
comfortable enough
not to go out in protest because they'd
rather stay home and watch the game so
to speak and this is not
to diminish uh civic activism it's not
to pretend that everybody's in a
comfortable position but there's
there's a swath of of the population
that may be in a different economy
without ready access to chiefs
cheap stuff from china and without ready
access to credit with which to buy that
stuff
might be less comfortable and thus more
eager to go out in protest now on the
other hand you have this kind of
um forced precarity people who recognize
wait um if i take a day off to go
protest i could lose my job or at least
not get paid that day
and then my health insurance is in
question and then i don't know if i have
food for my kids
and so that disincentivizes going out to
to protest what do you think of that as
a systemic analysis
uh that maybe so i mean the the russian
revolution
famously might not have happened if the
weather hadn't permitted
certain you know crossing of the rivers
and by by
large groups of people so it's not um
it's not impossible that there would be
would be things like that that would be
equally um determinative
of whether people are willing to go out
and and be
um be political on mass um
there's also though again
the relationship for example between the
protests that happened
this summer and the pandemic uh
i think is still un is misunderstood
underexplored
um they seem in some ways to have
nothing to do with each other
police violence is something that's
happened for a very long time the
pandemic
was it was almost like a short break
that people took from the pandemic
to deal with this urgent matter now
i think there's probably more to it than
that um
the effects on mass psychology
individual psychology of being pent up
of being prevented from seeing the faces
of other human beings
is immense uh and once that stops
i think a lot of things will actually
change they might not change in
predictable ways
but things like the politics of mass
gatherings
uh that could be one of the things that
that
turns out to to change a lot as a result
of
of coming of say a vaccine in terms of
the psychological
i've been thinking a lot about post
covid
i think that even when mathematically
things go back to what they were before
where during flu season you have a
higher risk of catching the flu
and it's less deadly than coronavirus
but it's the same as before coronavirus
i think that there will be risks that
were always there
that people weren't maybe thinking of
and you may see
folks particularly in certain risk
categories
who just during flu season might want to
wear a mask or might stay home or
i think there's going to be sort of a
realignment as a flex
as much as humans return to the mean and
go back to the way things were
i think that at least for for years
there are going to be aspects of this
with us
yeah i mean there's some just factual
knowledge that we have
that either didn't know before or we
didn't care about before
like the fact that you know during flu
season you can possibly save thousands
and thousands of lives by doing
something like wearing a mask
um every japanese person do that almost
no americans knew that so
that knowledge is with us for good what
i'm thinking of more
are is i'm thinking more about um
different types of psychological effects
i mean i i've had a
a strange pandemic in that i was
uh i was isolated as we were all told to
be for
for months at a time i'm glad i did that
and then i've gone out and i've reported
too so and i've moved from country to
country
too i've been traveling more than most
people this year
and have seen how the pandemic looks
from from place to place
and i would not have guessed from my
position of solitude in those first
months
how different the feeling in psychology
was
mass psychology was of going out and
experiencing places where the pandemic
hadn't hit as hard
so i i think we can be lulled into
thinking that that
um that nothing deeply has changed about
how we're looking at the world
um because it changes slowly and then
once
there's the the great pandemic jailbreak
because
the curve has been broken or the vaccine
has been distributed
then i think what we'll emerge and we
will discover
with great surprise how different the
world has become
while we were locked away that's that's
what i'm
actually mostly looking forward to i
think the world will be we'll discover
that
the world suddenly improves once we are
able to go out
but the the fact of change i have little
doubt about
massive change yes absolutely um
absolutely agree we've been speaking
with graham wood
a journalist who writes for the atlantic
and is also author of the book
the way of the strangers so appreciate
your time today graham
it was a pleasure the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about
half as much water nebia also offers a
number of shower accessories like
shelves and curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use the code pacman will get
15 off site wide
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
there are growing calls for conspiracy
theorist alex jones to be
arrested for threatening comments that
he made about president-elect joe biden
over the weekend at the supposed million
maga rally in dc which fell
just just a little bit short of a
million people
and alex jones talked about removing joe
biden
one way or another that was the language
he used take a look
and it's in the midst of this absolutely
unhinged rant i understand the video
quality is not good in this clip it's
actually atrocious
this is the best we were able to find
take a look we will never back down
to the satanic pedophile globalist new
world order
and their walking dead reanimated
corpse joe biden
and we will never recognize him
trump president trump had zero
connection to russians
no proof four years of investigation
with the biden's hits open and shut
so i don't know who's going to the white
house in 38 days
but i sure know this joe biden
is a globalist and joe biden will be
removed
one way or another
now one way or another suggests violence
it it alludes to assassination
given that joe biden won and states
certified the winds
and the electors voted and that joe
biden will be sworn in on january 20th
and the scariest thing about all of this
is that someone as prominent as alex
jones
ranting like this is bad enough but alex
jones is doing the rant in front of
exactly the type of crowd
that might actually get some ideas from
hearing alex jones say this stuff
and that really gets into the bulk of
the issue that
i i want to confront we have to confront
and i'm not exactly sure how
alex jones lawyers have previously said
in court that he's playing a character
on his show
now that's a very common legal defense
for these types when they say
insane things they will say it it's a
character
but that video clip i played for you is
not from a show it's a political rally
it's a political event
and alex jones is still saying these
things but fair enough maybe
simply saying it in these terms we have
to remove joe biden one way or another
maybe he doesn't mean violence maybe he
means impeachment or something
maybe it doesn't rise to anything beyond
mere political opinion but it's not just
that this is a crowd
that might fall for it and do something
thanks to alex jones without diagnosing
anyone
if you watch alex jones and think he's a
journalist
or someone giving you good information
like i know people who watch him as mere
entertainment
sort of like shock value or disaster
porn
okay but if you watch alex jones and
think you're getting information from a
journalist
and that maybe that's information that
that you could act on
you probably have some issues yourself
and i'm not vaguely throwing around the
term mentally ill and i know that it
would be fraught to do that
but i think that we can all understand
that the people most likely to see alex
jones rants
as a source of news and take them to
heart are people
that he is exploiting who have very real
issues of different kinds let's put it
that way without diagnosing anything
and so the question of how far playing a
character goes is a real
practical a serviceable question
jones lawyer stated on the record
that jones is playing a character and is
a performance artist and
argued that you can't judge alex jones
based on what he says on his show
that it would be like judging jack
nicholson when he played the joker
in batman which by the way was the first
movie i saw when i moved to the u.s
back in 1989 1990 but way more
people know when they watch batman and
they see the joker they know it's
fiction
they know these are actors the people
who would hear alex jones and think okay
he's sort of a news guy
in some way they are really
doing something that is a much more
precarious situation
batman and joker are obvious characters
alex jones is acting like a real person
who's acting under his own name and
that's why the legal argument that his
lawyers made falls apart
but it doesn't matter because he's still
influencing people's behavior
i actually believe the better analogy is
pro wrestling
where wrestlers sometimes wrestle under
their real names
and uh are are performing in a way
that's intended to get people to suspend
disbelief it sort of looks like real
wrestling
and case in point if a pro wrestler
whether in character or not
made a threat to an elected official i
think the secret service would
immediately act on it to see if it's a
real threat so
this is very very low and we
we really have a perfect storm here we
have trump insisting it was rigged oan
and newsmax supporting it and giving
giving oxygen to these ideas and people
like alex jones and the my pillow guy
mike lindell and others
fueling the fire and it could get very
ugly very quickly
um i mentioned earlier in the program
that there was a really important
milestone relating to fox news that had
been
achieved and i want to talk about that
now
for the first time ever newsmax tv
got a higher rating a larger audience
than fox news
at a particular point in time this has
never happened before and this relates
to
so many stories and issues that we're
following this story
is about the brewing republican civil
war this story is about the growing war
between some trumpists and even trump
and fox news
and this story is also about the next
two years of political media
recall that donald trump for the last
year but especially after the election
has started going after fox news
why because fox news accurately reported
sometimes that joe biden won the
election that's it
that's what fox news did that has
attracted the ire of the president
and many of his followers and trump
started talking about
fox is done you got to watch newsmax now
you've got to watch oan
and these channels newsmax and oam oan
are so
outrageous that they actually make fox
news look slightly reasonable
if you watch at certain times of day and
we've talked about how this will have an
effect and in fact
even at various trump rallies when they
interview attendees
and they are asked you know even fox
news has called this why don't you
believe it they will say
fox news is part of the left now you
have to watch oan and newsmax so
this is trickling down to
more and more people this idea that fox
is now part of the left
um and so this had a real impact in
terms of ratings as well this is just
one data point but it's the first of its
kind
monday night in what's called the demo
the key demographic of 25 to 54 year old
viewers
greg kelly reports which is a show on
newsmax
had more viewers than the martha
mccallum show on fox news at the exact
same time
now it was a really small margin 229 000
to 203
000 really small margin but it's still a
first because prior to the election
the numbers were not even close for
newsmax ever now one thing that remains
to be seen is whether newsmax grows
online when trump mentioned newsmax
newsmax got a ton of youtube subscribers
like for example they now have 1.7
million
we only have 1.1 almost 1.2 million but
in terms of
views on about half the days we get more
views on youtube
than newsmax does so just because people
subscribe doesn't necessarily mean
they're consuming the content
but even without knowing that this is a
huge media story because i've often
explained
it's not so much that it's the number of
people watching
fox news or newsmax or listening to rush
that matters
it's that they set the agenda for those
who watch
and that then trickles down through the
right wing a sphere
and with trump in the white house fox
news has literally been setting the
agenda something will appear on fox news
and within minutes trump tweets about it
and it becomes a story for hours
or for a day or two or even for weeks in
some cases so
even though only a few million people
might ever see one fox news show
it has agenda setting power and that's
what might change
after trump leaves office if trump
starts giving exclusives
to oan and newsmax even without huge
viewership
oan and newsmax could start agenda
setting for the right
and that again would be a completely
humiliating debasement
of american media and culture and
remember fox news really caught on
around the bill clinton impeachment fox
news started in 1996
and then when the clinton impeachment
took place from 98 to 99
fox news exploded and became more like
what it has been
recently in the exact same way trump's
entire they stole the election fiasco of
2020
could be what puts newsmax and oan in a
similar position
and sort of here to stay in right-wing
media which is really really scary for
me it's interesting because it'll be
fascinating to cover this for the next
two years
but for the country it's terrible and uh
the more people
that are getting the new their news from
outlets like this
uh the worse off the country is going to
be we have a voicemail number
which is 219 to david p
this is um okay so the this is the
voicemail from the san antonio troll and
he's calling with a cutesy little
fake accent but he actually brings up
some interesting aspects that just again
prove the degree of of lack of
understanding that a lot of these people
have
now the san antonio troll has been
calling multiple times a week for
months trying to get on and i'm just so
bored with him that i've not been
playing his voicemails
but there's actually something
instructive here so let's listen and
then discuss
hello pokemon um my name's tommy
i'm a long time listener i love your
show
um so i'm thinking pacman i like a lot
you know our progressives we have the
best ideas
they're better than everything we should
even share their ideas
all other ideas should be banned i knew
you with me on this but um
what i'm thinking as a progressive you
know a lot of the
the these racist right-wingers with all
races
um they think that uh the uh
you know that we uh we're doing they're
sharing
their do we should prove them wrong man
you know how we're for reparations we're
for higher taxes
we're for staying at home and not
working why don't you stop working
and only collect the cover check why
don't you pay higher taxes out of your
paycheck and why don't you pay your
appreciative paycheck back
i think if we do that if we do it first
then other people will like agree with
us and stuff right now
i don't know what do you think awesome
so this is um i mean obviously
this person is very very dumb but what's
interesting about it
is that there there are people on the
right who seem to
not understand the point of society
and government and and culture and what
constitutes policy so that's a very
you know david if you which i don't if
you think people shouldn't work and
should just get coveted money
why don't you stop working and get just
live off of covet money well first of
all i didn't get any coveted money i
didn't qualify for any coveted money
that's first of all so i didn't get any
money
from anybody for first and foremost um
secondly why don't i just choose to pay
more taxes
uh that's not policy me me choosing to
pay more taxes
changes absolutely nothing that's not
how we govern that's not how
modern societies make decisions
me saying i'm going to send the irs more
money which will mostly go
to defense spending anyway that's not
policy and that's not how how adults
actually govern and then why don't i pay
reparations i mean
i don't need one of the trademarks of
the san antonio troll
is reacting to things i've not
said i've not advocated for people to
start
paying reparations i've said that i
think it's a politically difficult thing
and my my views on it are not set in
stone but this is not a show that has
started saying people start
paying reparations so it's really
important to understand
and you know the i know that i'm taking
total idiocy
and trying to actually analyze it but
there is something in there that's
important which is
if you believe the tax rate should be x
why don't you just start paying that tax
rate
and that is mind-numbingly naive and
also
extraordinarily childish in the context
of
that is not the way a society decides
what its priorities
are um and you know i'm not trying to
convince the san antonio troll but i
think it's important to keep this in
mind
we have a great bonus show for you today
stickers
that signal whether you've been
vaccinated from covid
that could be the future and we're going
to talk about that number two
who did really well economically in 2020
we know like the uber billionaires did
really well
um but it's actually bigger than that
and we're going to talk about that on
the bonus show
and major development in the world of
electric vehicles toyota
has a game-changing new car battery that
is building on the successes we've
already seen from tesla and others
and we could be looking in the next five
years at
extraordinarily dramatic changes in
terms of range and charging speed and
capacity for electric vehicles which is
exactly what it might take
to get electric vehicle adoption to the
next level and bring down prices which
is also very important
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show and
i will tell you about today's insane
tech disaster
which hopefully you didn't notice we
actually had one of the biggest tech
disasters today in the last
probably two years of the show and i
think we cleaned it up
pretty well so i'll talk about that on
the bonus show as well get
instant access by becoming a member at
joinpakman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
magic spoon is the cereal that tastes
exactly like the delicious cereals from
your childhood except it has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect for a keto diet
to get free shipping go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman blinkist
is the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman nebia is a revolutionary
shower head that saves you money by
using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code pacman